we are extraordinary.
We can do more.
And another thing for Malawi,
and not just Malawi but other countries:
The laws which are there,
you know how a law is not a law until it is enforced?
The law which has just recently passed
and the laws that in other countries have been there,
they need to be publicized at the local level,
at the community level,
where girls' issues are very striking.
Girls face issues, difficult issues, at the community level every day.
So if these young girls know that there are laws that protect them,
they will be able to stand up and defend themselves
because they will know that there is a law that protects them.
And another thing I would say is that
girls' voices and women's voices
are beautiful, they are there,
but we cannot do this alone.
Male advocates, they have to jump in,
to step in and work together.
It's a collective work.
What we need is what girls elsewhere need:
good education, and above all, not to marry whilst 11.
And furthermore,
I know that together,
we can transform the legal,
the cultural and political framework
that denies girls of their rights.
I am standing here today
and declaring that we can end child marriage in a generation.
This is the moment
where a girl and a girl, and millions of girls worldwide,
will be able to say,
"I will marry when I want."
(Applause)
Thank you. (Applause)